hello
i'd like to thank the organizers for the
opportunity to tell you about the
non-aversive handling methods
that we've developed for mice a
refinement that has a big impact on mass
welfare
as well as reducing the compounds of
unnecessary stress
in animal research i'm going to talk
through some of the scientific evidence
that shows what a big effect these
handling methods have on mice
and then look at the practicalities of
using these methods
in place of tail handling and some tips
on how to implement them
successfully
but first domesticated mice are a lot
easier to handle of course
but we do know that background stresses
in the laboratory environment can have a
major impact
impact and confound the repeatability of
research
when we started to use laboratory mice
as genetically controlled models for
wild mice
in our own research i was really
surprised by how anxious they were
and how much that interfered with our
behavioral experiments
and indeed when we were running
experiments we found that we needed many
more
individuals of an in inbred strain than
we did of wild mice to show the same
level of effect
but why should domesticated laboratory
mice show such high anxiety when all we
were doing was actually handling them
and putting them into simple behavioral
tests that shouldn't
have been aversive
i'll just give you so wild mice
do get very stressed if you pick them up
by the tail in standard way that
laboratory mics are handled
so to see if this tail handling is what
was causing the problem
i compared three different methods for
picking up mice
and the differences were really quite
astounding so that led to
us as conducting a formal study which
was published in nature methods in 2010
because it turns out that the method
that you use to pick up mice
is critical to whether this causes
handling stress and anxiety
and it's this paper that won the nc3rs
prize in 2010
and the work that we've done since then
to show that these methods can be
practically applied in laboratories won
the swiss laboratory animals
association refinement prize in 2019
so what are these methods that we're
comparing a little background
so the first method is the traditional
tail handling method where we pick the
mouse up by the base of the tail between
thumb and forefinger
and we're not dangling these mice we're
using the best practice
of uh supporting the weight of the mouse
on the arm or the sleeve
or the hand once the animal has been
picked up
we're comparing that to a tunnel
handling method which is based on the
method
that we use for wild mice so here we're
encouraging the animals to enter a
tunnel
and picking them up in the tunnel and
then you can either use that to transfer
the animals to another location
or if you need them in the hand to
conduct procedures or to do health
checks
you can just tip them backwards out of
the tunnel onto your hand
and then replace them back in the cage
and then the third method that we've
used is cupping them on the open hand
domesticated mice of course don't show
the same
uh flight and jumping that wild mice do
and you can just pick them up on the
open hand without restraint once they're
used to being handled
so once they're used to being picked up
they will stay on the hand when you lift
the hand
getting them to stay on the hand in the
first place does require a few little
techniques to do that and i'll say a
little bit more about that later
in the talk on why
so we've compared those three different
handling methods
and over the past 10 years we and other
labs have assessed the effects
on mice from many different angles
we've looked at many behavioral tests
like voluntary interaction
how easy they are to handle this the
anxiety they show
also physiological stress responses
how they respond to rewards the
reliability of both behavioral and drug
testing
and also how the animals respond to
different procedures
very unusually all of these studies have
come to the same consistent conclusion
which is picking
that picking up mice by the tail has
negative effects on animals
that can be avoided by using our
alternative methods
now i won't have time to go through all
of this evidence of course
so i'll pick out some of the key
findings and one thing that i'm
particularly interested in uh is whether
animals
find handling aversive uh or whether
they will voluntarily interact with the
handler so
it's telling us something about the way
the animal itself
feels towards that handling of procedure
so to look at this we do a very simple
test
immediately after handling we put the
handling device back into the cage
and hold it unmoving so we can see
whether the animals will
approach and interact voluntarily and
these mice have just been
picked up by the tail and you can see
that they're really unwilling to uh
come and interact with the hand this
mouse does seem to be trying to escape
from the cage to avoid the hand
and when they do actually approach the
hand it's a really cautious type of
approach
they sort of sniff forward and then they
back off very different from the way
that these animals on the right hand
side now have just been handled in a
tunnel
and the first thing they do when you put
the tunnel back into the cage
is go straight back into the tunnel
they're much more willing to approach
the handling device and as you can see
here they'll touch it
they'll actually climb on it so they'll
put all their weight on it
and they'll go straight back inside the
tunnel so a much more free
interaction uh as they're exploring the
cage they're not just
sitting in a corner
started to look at this graph on the
right just summarizes the total time
that my spend interacting
with their handling device across three
different strains
and nine different handlers and you can
see there is a substantial difference
between the different methods
mice that were picked up in the tunnel
the blue bars there spend a lot of the
test time
interacting with the handling device the
tunnel and the hand-hold
holding the device whereas the mice that
were picked up by tails spend very
little
time uh interacting with the handler
mice picked up by cupping
show a sort of intermediate response
they're actually showing a lot more time
interacting than those picked up by the
tail but not quite as much as those
picked up by the tunnel
and particularly the male mice they show
a little bit more caution about
interacting with the hand after cupping
compared to the females
this this difference in their
willingness to interact with the handler
generalizes across strains across
handlers whether handlers
are really experienced or inexperienced
whether they're male or female
it generalizes across cage types across
different laboratories
and even whether mice are handled in the
light or the dark
we really see tremendous reproducibility
uh in these responses across many
different studies
really unusual to see that consistency
in
a behavioral response across so many
different factors
but uh in this test the tunnel handled
mice of course are responding to the
tunnel
while the tail and cup handled mice are
responding to the
hand but for the tunnel handled mice
it's not just the tunnel
that they're more willing to interact
with i'm a
if we test the tunnel handled mice
and look at their response even if we
just put the hand back
in we see that actually they're also a
lot more willing to interact with the
hand
than the tail handled micelle these
animals are essentially just
much more willing to explore and they
will start to get used to the hand and
they'll start climbing on the hand and
even climb up your arm
if you'll allow them to whereas the tail
handled animals are showing a much more
aversive response they spend very little
time interacting with the hand
and they're very loath to actually touch
the hand
so we see a really different response
between these different
methods so as well as
interaction we can see big differences
in response in lots of other measures
that we can zoologists
so one of the measures that we've looked
at
is urination and defecation during
handling
because animals which are highly
stressed show much increased rates of
urination and defecation
and it's something we can compare easily
between the different methods
and what we see is that the mice that
are picked up by the tail
show much increased rates of urination
and defecation
a really typical sign of quite a high
stress response
um it's not just us that have shown this
a number of other studies that have have
also repeated this
and measured urination and defecation
and find exactly the same thing
with now i was particularly interested
in
looking at anxiety because it was this
that really
uh alerted me to the potential problem
of picking up mice by the tail
um so whatever we wanted to test is
whether that actual picking mice up by
the tail
causes that high anxiety response that
we notice
in laboratory mice so we've used a
number of tests
perhaps the simplest test is an open
field test
anxious animals will avoid going into
open areas
in an open field test we deliver the
animals into the center of an open field
and then record their behavior over a
five minute test
and what we see is that tail handled
animals spend much less time in the
center of the arena
than those handled by tunnel or capping
and they're also much slower to return
to the center
once they've been released into the
arena and what i want you to really
notice here is that these aren't small
subtle differences
they're really big this is a very major
difference in behavior between these
animals
certainly between the tail and the top
and the tunnel and cupping methods
we find no difference actually in
anxiety behavior between those that
have been picked up by tunnel and those
that have been picked up
by cupping a strong
we've also looked at behavior in an
elevated plus maze as a really well
validated test of anxiety and again
the tail-handled mice consistently show
greater anxiety in this test
so the elevated plus maze has two closed
arms which are surrounded by high walls
and two open arms and the
uh tail handled animals spend much less
time on the open arms than those handled
by tunnel
or by cupping and they show a lot more
risk assessment behavior where they sort
of sit in the center of the maze
and just uh um stretch out onto the open
arms without actually going there
a very typical sign of anxious animals
interest in one indeed these tests have
been repeated
by many other people and um there have
also been
additional tests social novelty tests
and a light dart box box tests
and all of these studies have found the
same thing
that mice picked up by the tail have
higher anxiety
compared to those picked up in a tunnel
or by cupping
on the open hand so even though
typically we see quite a lot of
variation in these types of behaviors
between strains
between sexes between laboratories on
this particular
factor how the animals are handled it's
really consistent
rodent behavior now besides the obvious
impact
of these differences in anxiety and
stress on animal welfare
uncontrolled background step stress can
cause major compounds
in scientific experiments and reduce
data reliability
so we tested the mice in a behavioral
test to see
whether the method of handling actually
influenced the reliability
of the behavioral outcomes of the test
and we decided to use a very simple test
that any mouse should be able to do
this is an habituation disabituation
test
which tests the ability of mice to
recognize a difference between two
stimuli
and in this test what you do is you
present the mice
with the same stimulus in a series of
tests conducted
quite quickly after each other and as
the animals start to recognize
the same stimulus their investigation
declines
and then on the fourth trial you replace
that stimulus with a novel stimulus
and if the mice recognize that that
stimulus is novel then their
investigation of it
increases and uh it's this um
this habituation or so called this
habituation that the test
is measuring so it's the difference
between the sniffing of a very familiar
stimulus
with a novel stimulus and to make this
really easy for the mice we use
urine cues mice are extremely good at
discriminating between urine cues
so we used urine cues from genetically
distinct individuals
so they should really be able to tell
that difference very easily
and communicate so here you can see the
results for
uh mice that were handled by tunnel here
you can see that they show
um a dish habituation sorry an
habituation as they
repeatedly get presented with the same
stimulus
and here's the response we're looking
for when we swap the first urine
stimulus for another
urine stimulus from a different
individual then they recognize it's
different
and we see the dishabituation response
really nice and consistent
every single mouse in the test could do
it
these are the responses for mice that
were handled by cupping
and here we can see that yes we do see a
dish habituation response it is
significant but you can also see
that we've got much much more variance
in these animals uh it's just
significant uh
but also some of the animals uh didn't
actually respond properly to the test so
we did see a response
a little bit more variable and that's
quite typical actually for cupping
because in these tests we didn't subject
the animals to a lot of handling
their only prior experience of handling
was during cage cleaning
every fortnight and then when they were
put into the test
and we know that for cap handling
animals do
take quite a lot of experience with cup
handling before they start to show very
easy responses to it
so that's pretty much what we might
expect to see for cup handling
now these are the results for mice that
are handled by tail
and i haven't forgotten to plot the data
here i've plotted the median responses
and the median responses of these mice
were zero investigation
the test failed because the animals
failed to investigate
the stimulus and this is really typical
of this test when people try
doing this test on laboratory mice it's
a test that is very difficult to carry
out
in a novel test arena where you have to
handle the animals to put them into the
arena
and indeed people have completely failed
to get this test to work
in novel arenas and have ended up having
to
singly house the animals so that they
can conduct the test in their home cages
without actually handling the animals
but actually if you handle the animals
using a non-aversive method
they will do this response in an
unfamiliar test arena
really really well the actual problem
here
is that the animals are responding
with anxiety in the test and when we
look at the behavior that these
tail handled animals were showing it is
typical of the behavior
of a really anxious animal they're
staying around the
outer walls they're not exploring the
enclosure properly
and they're just failing to investigate
the stimuli and indeed
even when we put the stimuli against the
side walls where the animals were
spending most of their time
they still failed to investigate the
stimuli
the anxiety was just really interfering
with them showing a response
nation now my laboratory of course is
interested in behavior
and many others are more interested in
looking at the effects of physiological
stress
and whether stress from handling can
interfere
with their physiological experiments so
this is data from a laboratory that
studies diabetes
where stress is a major confounding
factor
that affects blood glucose and glucose
tolerance tests
so this laboratory compared tail
handling uh mice
with uh cupping them on the open hand
and found that the cup handling
uh significantly reduced both the blood
glucose
and corticosterone stress responses of
the mice
and on top of that it also improved the
glucose tolerance
responses of the animals so really had
quite a big effect on these animals
showing that cup handling was a much
more reliable technique
to use in these in these studies
on top of that jasmine clarkson has
looked at the effect of handling on
chronic stress by measuring
the adrenal gland weights after mice
have been handled
either by picking up by the tail or in a
tunnel
and showed that the adrenal glands are
much heavier in tail handled mice than
tunnel handled wise after
a few weeks of handling suggesting there
really is a chronic stress response
to tail handling although we are
now one of the things that worries
people about
using something like tunnel handling is
that the mice don't get used to being
restrained and the same with cup
handling although you're putting them on
the hand
they're not actually being physically
restrained but of course for many
procedures in the laboratory we do need
to restrain animals
so i think that the concern is that once
animals uh start to have to be
restrained will they get a very strong
response to that
restraint but that actually isn't the
case
uh what you can see here uh is an
experiment where we have handled
uh the animals by their standard method
tail tunnel or cup
and then immediately after they've been
handled
we then restrain them by the scruff in a
standard way and then we've measured
their voluntary interaction with the
handler again
immediately after that scruffing
experience
and actually the only animals to respond
in a negative way to scruffing
are the tail handled animals so these
animals were already showing a poor
response
uh once we've restrained them by the
scruff they're showing an even more
negative response in not being willing
to approach the handler and that is
really very typical
it's the tail handled animals or even
though they've had experience of
restraint
when you give them another experience
actually they respond really strongly to
it whereas this really didn't affect the
the tunnel handled animals or the
cup-handled animals and they showed no
more anxiety
than they did uh before we did the
scruffing so they're very tolerant
actually of being
restrained by the scruff um because
we've got them used to being handled in
a non-aversive way
to start with and importantly
um actually you can restrain the mice by
the tail once you've picked them up
that itself isn't aversive it's only
being picked up by the tail
that induces the subversive response so
once you have the animal in the hand
whether you pick them up
in a tunnel or by cupping you can then
restrain the animals by the tail or by
the scruff
it's particularly useful to be able to
retur to to restrain the animal by the
tail if you want to
inspect its abdomen for example that
isn't going to cause your problem
it's the way that you're picking animals
up that causes the issue
often study animal so
there is a lot of evidence now that
picking up mice by the tail
is highly aversive and causes
substantial stress and anxiety
these non-aversive methods on the other
hand are really over
seem to overcome that but is it really
practicable
to use these non-aversive tunnel or
cupping methods
for routine handling in the laboratory i
think one of the things that is
particularly
of concern is how long do we need to
handle the animals to get them familiar
with these non-aversive methods before
they're effective
and do we need to have tunnels in the
cage certainly in all
our experiments we provide animals with
tunnels in their home cage but is it
actually necessary
could you just use a clean tunnel to
pick them up and i think one of the
things that is particularly
of potential concern is even if we use
non-aversive methods for routine
handling
once animals are used in procedures that
might induce some pain or distress
is that going to completely negate the
effect of the non-aversive methods
so kelly goulet came to work with me as
a phd student to try and address some of
these
practical issues in seminar
and i think some of the the um uh
thing of particular concern particularly
if you are an animal care person
and you've got to handle the animals on
a regular basis that that mustn't take
too much time
and when we first started uh doing this
work
we followed the standard practice of
assuming that
if we wanted to familiarize animals with
handling
we needed to pick them up and hold them
for a reasonable period of time so they
could get used to it
but the good news actually is that you
don't need to do that
if you use a non-aversive method for
picking them up in the first place
that in itself is good enough you don't
have to then hold the animals to get
them used to being handled
you just have to not use an aversive
method so what we found that there was
no difference
in whether after we picked them up we
held the animals for just
essentially two seconds about the time
it takes you to transfer an animal
from one cage to another or whether you
use much more extended periods
so the time of handling actually doesn't
seem to have
any real effect and also how frequently
you handle
is not that important at least for tail
handling and tunnel handling
so if you tunnel handle at cage cleaning
that is sufficient to get a positive
response even if you are only cleaning
the animals out only quite infrequently
maybe on a two or three weekly basis
and what we found was that on the other
hand
the bad news is that tail handling uh
induces a negative response even if you
handle them
only really briefly and perhaps only at
cage cleaning that will still induce
this really
strong negative response
but for tunnel handling um if if you you
you can just pick them up in the tunnel
and they start to respond really
positively very quickly
cupping them on the other hand does take
a little longer
here you can see some data where we pick
the animals up
for different periods of time and the
difference of periods of time don't
really make very much difference
certainly the two seconds had the had
the least positive response
but really we weren't getting a very
good response after five handing
sessions
and this is very typical of cup handling
especially with the slightly more
nervous strains what we found is that
you need to have more than five handling
sessions for cup handling
to for animal animals to become really
accustomed with cup handling
typically it takes them about seven to
ten handling sessions before they get
comfortable
with this method so that's one of the
slight downsides of cup handling
it's very quick to do you don't need to
have a tunnel to do it
but it takes the mice uh quite a bit
longer to get used to that compared
to tunnel handling actual enclosure now
tunnels as i said uh when we do
we in our cages we have tunnels for
handling
present in the home cages so that
animals can get very familiar with these
these tunnels before we ever have to
handle them
the question is do you need to have a
tunnel in the home cage
in some cases it may be quite difficult
to have that tunnel especially if you
have
quite small cages and there are other
things that you want to have in that
cage
and what we found is that home cage
tunnels
do provide an additional enrichment in
the cages so the animals use them quite
a lot
and one of the advantages to that is
that the animals get so used to them
it's very easy to get them to enter the
tunnels very readily
but in terms of the actual responses of
the animals if you can't have a home
cage tunnel
you still get very positive responses to
unfamiliar external tunnels that you
would just use for handling them
it's still a lot better than tail
handling but there are some additional
advantages if you can have the tunnel in
the home cage
especially for the more nervous strains
but the mice will get used to
going into a clean tunnel really very
quickly uh so it's perhaps uh
particularly beneficial if you're not
handling them very much a home cage
tunnel will just help that little bit
more
as to model so what we've seen
is that these methods are actually quite
practical to use they
you don't need extended handling to make
use of them
but is any of that of any use at all if
the animals
then go into an experiment where they're
experiencing
procedures that may induce some distress
or pain
so one of the things that we've looked
at is the response of animals
once they have experienced a particular
procedure and here you can see an
experiment
where we've looked at the response to
subcutaneous injection
so here we've got four different groups
of animals it's a little bit more
complex
complicated
so i'll just show you at the top you can
see the results for voluntary
interaction at the bottom we have
an open field test where we're measuring
anxiety
for the four different groups the um
hatched uh bars show animals which have
been picked up from their cage
restrained by str scruff and given a
subcutaneous injection
and this is their response after their
first injection and this is after their
fifth day
daily injections and the control animals
here in the solid bars
have just been picked up from their cage
by their normal method and then replaced
so they've not been restrained they've
not had injections
and here you can see we have tail
handled animals in those two categories
and tunnel handled animals
and what you should be able to see very
easily is there is a massive difference
in response again
according to the method by which they've
been picked up the tunnel handled
animals are showing much more voluntary
interaction than the tail handled
animals
and they're showing much less anxiety
than the tail handled animals
after both first injection and five
injections
and actually we can see no response to
the injection
even after five daily injections we
still couldn't see
any response uh to the actual injection
itself
the handling method was having all of
the effects here
so although we typically would think of
injection as being something that the
animals are going to respond
quite badly to it turns out that the
handling method is far more
important
lindsay henderson has also recently
published a study
where they show very similar effects uh
that tunnel handling
uh reduces negative responses to ip
injection
uh or to anesthesia uh compared to those
picked up by the tail
so this does seem to be uh quite a
general type of response
natural condition
here you can see something which perhaps
involves the animals in
a little bit more obvious distress this
is
the response to daily gavage
is used for for drug administration this
is a
study by nakamura and suzuki where they
compared
the responses of tunnel-handled animals
with tail-handled animals
when they had to give them a daily
gavage
and what they can see what you can see
here is that clearly once they started
doing
daily garage the voluntary interaction
of their animals did drop
but it dropped in both the tunnel and
the tail handled animals
and still the tunnel-handled animals
were still coming to the handler and
interacting voluntarily
although they did they were a little bit
more wary it was still a much stronger
response
than the tail handled animals which
really started to
avoid approaching the handler so you see
this much better
voluntary interaction they also found
that the tunnel handled animals were
easier to handle
using an independent rating scale they
showed that even despite the experience
of daley gavage
the animals tunnel handled animals still
showed reduced anxiety
and perhaps particularly importantly
they found that the tunnel handled
animal
animals had reduced variation in
pharmacological testing
so this was a real benefit from the
study not just
for the welfare of the animals but also
improved
their pharmacological tests
things and behavior so
the good news from all of that is that
procedures don't reverse the positive
effects of using non-aversive methods
even if those procedures do involve a
degree of distress or potential pain
and they really are very practical to
use you don't need to spend a lot of
time handling the animals
you can just replace tail handling with
these methods
but i think for people who have always
picked up mice by the tail
there are a lot of worries about
changing to these non-aversive methods
i think in particular people do worry
that it's going to take them
more time that it's going to be more
awkward they won't be able to do some
things
maybe they won't be able to handle as
easily if they've got small cages
lots and lots of worries i think
inevitably thinking about a change
does immediately make you think of all
the potential problems and just
i think there is an immediate assumption
when you see these techniques they're
just not going to be as practical
as picking up mice by the tail
so to help we have partnered with the
nc3rs in the uk
so that we can provide people with a lot
of resources
and we have set up a special mouse
handling hub
on the nc3rs website i've given you the
url here
and here we've put a lot of resources
like we we have made a
mouse handling tutorial that will take
new handlers all the way through
the use of mice and some of the initial
scientific evidence
as well as tips for how to handle the
animals but there's also a lot of other
information there not just the tutorial
but short video clips that you can use
in training
and i'm going to show you a few of those
just to show you um some good tips
uh um to to doing these this handling
well
you'll find uh frequently answered
questions looking at how you can
practically implement these
in laboratories there's a summary of all
the research papers
not just the bits i've shown you here
but actually it summarizes all of the
research that we know that has been done
on these method and you can also get um
a poster free from nc3rs uh if you
contact them
uh it's a poster to put up in your
animal facilities giving
lots of hints as to um how to best uh
uh implement these methods uh not just
what to do but also some of the things
perhaps
to try and avoid for good practice
i think the real key here is making sure
that people have good skills in learning
these new handing techniques that they
can actually handle
as well with the tunnel as they can with
the tail before you roll it out
what we what you don't want to do is
sort of start doing this and start
thinking that you're going to be able to
do this straight away on a lot of mice
and it's not going to take you more time
it will i'll be quite honest it usually
takes a few
may it could be a few days it could be a
few weeks depending on your skills
to learn to do these techniques really
really well
but once you have learned these
techniques you should be able to do them
as quickly as picking up by the tail
also neat
now i know that people are often
skeptical to start with that they're
really going to see a big difference and
this
really is a practical thing to do my own
chief animal technician john waters
uh was exactly the same uh when i first
started this research and we found the
results
i asked him if we could implement the
new methods uh in our own animal
facility
and he really didn't think it would be
practical uh he just thought this was
going to ruin his
daily life he would never be able to fit
in the work
but he agreed to give it a go because
he'd seen the data and he could see what
a big effect it was having on the
animals
and since then he has been a massive
champion
i mean john really worked out how to do
a lot of
normal um things around the unit by
using these non-aversive techniques
and he's helped a lot of other
technicians uh to
be able to implement things and because
of that he has
a very well deserved a number of awards
himself
and really seen this from a sort of
technician's perspective
as to how to do this on a daily basis
and we hear very similar things from
those people who have changed
in particular people say it's not as
difficult as they anticipated
um they particularly recommend everybody
should train first and
implement slowly so that you are really
good at the handling techniques before
you try and take on
a lot of animals i think people worry
about whether they can do the health
checks in the same way
but health checks are fine once you
adapt to the new
way of handling always people report
animals are more relaxed they're easier
to handle and they get fewer bites
and in particular new trainees are much
less scared
of handling bite with a tunnel so
trainers tell us
that it's much easier to train new
trainees because they're not scared of
the animals
and not just uh in in using uh these
techniques but also
because they're not scared of the
animals they find doing things like
scruffing
and restraint of that sort much easier
to do
and i think one of the things perhaps i
wasn't expecting when i was doing this
because i was really just thinking
of the animals and the also the impact
on the science
is that people say it really increases
their personal satisfaction
john has certainly said that this is a a
really big thing for him he feels much
closer to the animals
the interaction with the animals is so
much better but people just say they
would not go back
to tail handling use control and indeed
if you want to
hear what people think that have
implemented these new techniques in
their own facilities
nc3rs has published some interviews
from technicians and training officers
who have implemented these methods in
their
own facilities and they talk a little
bit about their experience
of how to do this in a way that
peop people find easy to take on so if
you have chance i would
definitely recommend you listen to some
of those people i think they're really
quite inspiring
it's it's it's certainly something to
take on particularly if you
uh have colleagues who are just not so
sure they haven't been they haven't
listened to a talk about this
it just sounds like more work to them uh
then perhaps
hearing other people and hearing that
they found this a really positive
experience
might be a useful thing for them to hear
old laboratory
so finally i think perhaps the most
important thing
i can tell you is uh how to
implement these methods successfully um
is
you really do need to get good technique
um i think it's one of those things that
while you see the videos it sort of
looks interesting and then you get a
tunnel in your hand and it doesn't go
quite so well
uh so i'd just like to sort of show you
some some good tips for
how you actually handle with the tunnel
and how you get uh the animal
quickly into the tunnel without any any
fuss issues
so i'm showing you in a big cage because
it's actually slightly harder to handle
in a big cage and you can see there
i've held the tunnel against the side
wall of the cage
and then you use the other hand to
encourage the animal into the tunnel
now what you don't want to do is to put
that tunnel in the center of the cage
because now when you encourage the
animal to go in
it's just going to run straight past i
don't think this house knows it's
supposed to go into that tunnel
it's just seen the hand coming towards
it and gone in the opposite direction
so you need to just put that put the if
you put the um
tunnel against the side wall there's
nowhere else for the mouse to go
and notice we're taking the mouse to the
tunnel not the other way around
now here you can see that you're just
using the hand to block you're not
actually using the hand
to encourage the animal in that's not
going to work
you can see this message just getting
frustrated it's been blocked into a
corner
and doesn't particularly want to go in
the tunnel what you need to do is just
encourage the animal into the tunnel
and indeed if it doesn't go straight in
and many animals will
but if it doesn't then you just touch
the back of the animals
and it will go straight in now you don't
want to do this
do not chase the animal around with the
tunnel it never works
or only very rarely works it's a really
um
you'll get very very frustrated if you
do that instead of that
you are holding the tunnel still and
bringing the mouse
to the tunnel and i it's very very
tempting
to when the mouse moves to move the
tunnel with it but try not to do that
hold the tunnel steady get used to
taking the mouse to the tunnel
and you will see that works really
quickly
every time um to drill down
so here is an example of cleaning out
a cage it's an ivc cage using the tunnel
handling technique you can see there is
already a clean cage set up
by the side with a clean tunnel in it
and we're cleaning out the cage
on the left hand side sorry on the right
hand side
and here you see the tunnel goes in the
other hand is used just to encourage the
mouse into the tunnel
and now because we're using cleaned uh
clear tunnels
it's very easy to actually inspect the
animals in the tunnels
and one of the nice things about using a
clear tunnel is that the animal is free
to move around
so you can really see if there is
anything wrong with that animal
if you want to inspect it more closely
of course you can tip it out onto your
hand but here we're just doing some
inspections and just checking that the
animal
is fine and you'll notice that when they
go into the new cage they go straight
back into the clean tunnel
that is in there they have no fear of
these tunnels at all
very easy to get them in now i've paused
the video here
because actually i want to see what what
happens when you don't
place the tunnel correctly and actually
make it such that the mouse can go
uh straight past you so what you're
going to see now
is that the handler puts that tunnel in
a different place in the cage
but they've not prepared it correctly so
that they're not blocking the animal
uh from going elsewhere and just see
what happens
into the mechanism so here you see now
the tunnel's gone over onto the right
hand side
but there was nothing blocking the
animal going in the other direction
and now we're getting a little bit of
chasing the animal around
and only got a good handling once the
tunnel was back into a secure place
and the animal was brought back to it
let's just perhaps see that
again so you can see what happened see
the tunnel went into a place the animal
just avoided the tunnel entrance it
wasn't properly
um blocked to go so it couldn't go past
and now we just once we get the animal
into a secure place for handling
we can very easily get it in and i think
i would recommend to you when you first
start
that you practice it doesn't matter
which hand you hold the tunnel in
whichever is most convenient for you
so that you can use the other hand but
practice so that you can very easily
isolate that mouse into one corner and
push it into the tunnel
once you get good at that then try with
other placements of the tunnel around
the cage
so you can work out the best placement
of the tunnel and your hand
and you will gradually find that as you
get better and better at this
you will soon be able to place the
tunnel correctly in different parts of
the cage
to very quickly get the mouse wherever
it is but i think when you first start
it's a lot easier to get the mouse to
come to the tunnel in a standardized
place
and get really good at that first
comes involved now what about cup
handling
now on the surface cup handling looks
really easy
you're just going to scoop up the animal
onto your hand
and hold it there as you lift it up the
problem with cup handling is it is a
little harder because you need to
understand
how to get mice to stay on the hand and
how to recognize
if a mouse is not going to stay on the
hand because we don't want mice
jumping all over the place so cup
handling is suitable
for perhaps older animals animals which
are already familiarized with handling
uh and not so suitable for young jumpy
animals especially
especially uh those animals just uh
first after weaning
and i would say that cup handling isn't
really good for
new handlers i think they need to start
to to understand mice a little bit
better
and get used to handling them before
they use this technique but for more
experienced handlers
this is a very convenient technique you
don't necessarily need a tunnel to do it
but the trick is how do you get mice to
stay on the hand before they're familiar
with this technique and there are a
number of methods that you can do
and i think this method is probably the
easiest it is using a tunnel
to familiarize animals to being picked
up in the first place
so here i will show you these animals
have never been cup handled
and what we do first of all is get them
used to being picked
up in a tunnel and when they're steady
in a tunnel they stop
sort of showing any anxiety about being
picked up then you can pick
that you can tip the animals out
backwards onto the hand and they will
stay there
but don't do that before the animals
have got used to being picked up
but the animals that get picked up in a
tunnel get very
relaxed they're not anxious animals and
so once they've got used to the tunnel
and i would say
pick them up in a tunnel maybe three or
four times before you attempt this
and then you can tick the animals
backwards onto your hand
now that's fine for older animals if
you've got
really jumpy animals they will still try
and jump off the hand so you do need to
be able to recognize that
in that in your animals and don't try
cup handling for those animals which are
still
rather jumpy but for this is essentially
an alternative to tunnel handling and in
our lab we use the two interchangeably
so we get animals used to being picked
up in a tunnel
and then we can either pick them up in a
tunnel or scoop them
onto a hand if we're using them in a
behavioral test
we will always pick them up in a tunnel
because it is just
that much less likely to cause any
anxiety in the animals
and we've then got really calm animals
going into our tests
but for routine handling if you want to
inspect the animals
and it's quicker for you to pick them up
on the hand then get them used to being
picked up
and then you can just scoop them up onto
the hand now
there is another taste and that is
to with the first few times that you
pick up the animals instead of picking
them up on the open hands
just uh pick them up between closed
hands
very loosely held around the mouse and
you will feel the animal
sort of trying to push between your
fingers and trying to get out so wait
for the animal to calm down it should
take about five to ten seconds
no more than that and if it then calms
down
you can open your hands and just check
on the behavior of that animal
and as long as it's not a really jumpy
animal it will stay on the hands
so you can do this and just be very you
will need to watch the animal but if
you're an experienced handler
you should find this works pretty well
and i know people get very concerned
that they might get bitten
uh when they do this but really if
you're approaching the animals very
carefully
and you know you're not squeezing the
animal it'll just try and push between
your fingers
but i have to say i had not been bitten
uh like this except when a
an adult male uh weed all over my hand
and then i
forgot to clean my glove before i
handled an unfamiliar male and he bit me
i think it was a response to the urine
rather than being cupped on the hand
because no other mouse has ever bitten
me
picking them up this way and another
method you can use
is when you're transferring mice at cage
cleaning
you can just scoop them and transfer
them between closed hands in this way
and once you've done that for uh several
several times
the animals really start to calm down
and you will find that you can just
scoot them on
open hands after that but i would just
warn you please don't try this technique
with jumpy animals particularly with
young animals or if you've got
any particularly jumpy strains that are
always difficult to handle
tunnel handling is a lot more secure and
i would really uh recommend that
generating so some take-home points from
my talk
picking up mice by the tail induces
strong handling aversion
stress and anxiety this negatively
impacts animal welfare and it's a really
surprisingly strong response
the animals are harder to handle and it
can be a major compound in research
which is
sensitive to stress and an awful lot of
research we know is indeed sensitive to
stress
however that can be easily avoided by
picking up mice
with non-aversive handling methods and
we've shown that this is really highly
repeatable it really does seem to work
on lots of different strains both sexes
it doesn't matter with the handler is
male or female whether they've had a lot
of experience or very little experience
we always seem to get the same responses
in using these non-aversive handling
methods
so i particularly recommend that you use
a tunnel or perhaps other
objects within the home cage may work
also
you can cut them on the open hand once
the animals are habituated to being
picked up
but do bear in mind that the first thing
the animals need to get used to
is just being picked up from the cage
and until they get used to that they are
quite jumpy fortunately you can still
restrain them
by the scruff or by the tail once you've
picked them up
using a non-aversive method and you can
still conduct
procedures even if those do induce uh
some pain or distress
when you need to it's not going to
reverse the response to the non-aversive
handling methods
and i think we have shown that these are
easily incorporated into normal
husbandry
it should take you little or no longer
than tail handling once you are
competent
but it does take you a little time to
become competent in the first place so
you will need to spend a little bit of
time
just getting your techniques really good
and making sure that you can handle
really quickly
and easily using these methods the mice
themselves only need brief
familiarization particularly with
tunnels we don't need
to handle them for prolonged periods to
get them familiar with handling as long
as we use a non-aversive method to pick
them up
cupping on the open hand does require
more handling experience
and the response of the mice is strain
and age dependent
so use that with caution use it when
it's safe
otherwise use a tunnel because that
seems to work
in all situations and there are real
strong benefits to using these
non-aversive techniques
uh it's better for animal welfare the
animals are easier to handle
we see improved reliability of response
measures particularly where these
responses are susceptible to stress
effects
and also for the for the handlers we
actually see improved job satisfaction
because people really enjoy that much
better interaction
with animals instead of the animals
trying to run away from you they come to
you they actually want to climb on you
they want to interact
and that has to be uh good for everybody
natural so i just like to finish by
acknowledging the very many people who
have helped with this research
particularly all the people who have
helped with handling the animals in my
own
group and have been very good about
handling the animals and letting me
record
the the responses of the animals also
particularly to
nc3rs for helping particularly to
put together resources to train people
and that can be used by others to other
collaborators
particularly to our funders and of
course to the mice themselves
without whom this research would not
have been possible
and uh thank you for listening thank you
for behavior in wild rodents under
laboratory conditions
is challenging but wild mice will
actually cooperate surprisingly well
with the careful approach and handling
methods that we've developed